Etiopía conmemora dos años de uno de los
conflictos más mortíferos del mundo el
gobierno se felicitó del acuerdo de paz
finalmente firmado el miércoles con las
autoridades del tigre tras semanas de
negociaciones
en todo el país y en nuestra ciudad por
un lado para recordar el ataque que se
llevó a cabo y por otro lado la victoria
que se logró por nuestras fuerzas de
defensa para mantener la soberanía de
nuestro país al día siguiente de la
firma por nuestro gobierno de los
acuerdos de paz en Sudáfrica Esto hace
de este día una conmemoración especial
la guerra entre el gobierno central
etíope y la región Rebelde del tigre
empezó en la noche Del 3 al 4 de
noviembre de 2020 provocó una crisis
humanitaria en el país y al menos dos
millones de personas fueron desplazadas
la paz tranquiliza a la población
volver a nuestra antigua vida pacífica
incluso nuestra economía se vio afectada
por la guerra
todas las partes del conflicto
cometieron excesos y crímenes contra la
humanidad según amnistía internacional
la paz Es mejor que la guerra hay que
tener en cuenta algunos puntos que deben
ser claros y precisos y el público debe
conocerlos y también La tregua debe ser
implementada cuidadosamente para que no
volvamos a caer en la guerra aparte de
eso no hay otra opción que la pasas
la firma del acuerdo da Esperanza a los
civiles pero la paz sigue siendo frágil
el conflicto implica varios actores
entre ellos eritrea aliada al gobierno
etíope y que fue la gran ausente de
estas negociaciones